ja es ging heute martialisch los an
diesem 22 november einen durchaus
sonniger tag in berlin aber um 10 uhr
gab es eine pressekonferenz vom
bundesgesundheitsminister und jens spahn
teilt mit in gewisser weise
apokalyptischer manier dass am ende
dieses winters also jeder bundesbürger
entweder von corona genesen sei geimpft
sei oder eben gestorben sein und das ist
eine apokalypse das sind aussagen die
kennen wir bereits in der korona
pandemie man erinnere sich an die
aussagen vom von markus söder den
bayerischen ministerpräsidenten der
folge vor einem jahr sagte dass jeden
tag in deutschland
quasi ein vollbesetztes flugzeug
abstürzen würde dieser drastischen
vergleich der sollte einmal mehr angst
schüren und ebenfalls von ihren sparen
die gleiche wirkung heute haben aber das
an schön ist das eine das andere ist am
ende das politische versagen was damit
kassiert werden soll wir haben es also
wieder einmal damit zu tun apokalypse
frist argument so darf das nicht sein
lieber jens spahn am ende muss es
eigentlich eine entschuldigung geben
genau für die dinge die in dieser
pandemie falsch gelaufen sind und keine
angstmacherei ja ich
muss ihnen dabei pflicht ich glaube sie
treffen da er den wunden punkt ich habe
mich auch gefragt dass ich das gehört
habe in der schweiz wird langsam zeit
dass jens spahn seine fünf millionen
villa wo in grunewald oder in dahlem
begonnen sich dann ein bisschen selber
runter kochen und vielleicht noch ein
gedanke der mir einfach in den sinn
gekommen ist bei diesen wirklich sehr
martialischen nicht angemessenen
aussagen im grunde wenn man das etwas
zur kenntlichkeit erstellen möchte
erleben wird durch hier eine art einen
totalitären mechanismus also sie haben
eine politik die systematisch führt also
panik sieht das vorantreibt gibt ja
keine beruhigenden aussagen und wenn
dann sind sie einfach viel an sorgen so
nach dem muster
versorgen und wenn du als politiker
angst schießt dann produzierst du auch
aus weil diese angst gebiert einen hass
und diese haus richtet sich dort in
gegen irgendwelche sündenböcke regen
irgendwelche minderheiten jetzt haben
sich alle verbindet die mehrheit
gegen die ungeimpften die minderheit was
er völlig verrückt ist denn die
geimpften können ja diese pandemie auch
weiter geben nicht nur die umgebung also
was soll das das ergibt ja gar keinen
sinn und das finde ich brandgefährlich
für eine demokratie das gilt nicht nur
für deutschland ist auch bei uns der
fall in der schweiz wir haben hier eine
art sündenbock demokratie kreierte eine
spaltung einer zerklüftung der
gesellschaft und mit solchen sätzen
gießen die da einfach noch mehr power
ins feuer ich muss es so drastisch
ausgedrückt aber absolut richtig also
wir sehen die spaltung der gesellschaft
ist so groß wie noch nie die menschen
haben sich auf die tyrannei der
ungeimpften vereinbart und wir sehen
auch dass die presse aber auch die
politik immer weiter die angst schüren
das ist seit zwei jahren kontinuierlich
werden wir mit mit horrorzahlen
konfrontiert libyen menschen sterben
werden 100.000 am tag zwar geheißen und
dann hat irgendwann geheißen wenn wir 60
prozent geimpft haben dann haben wir
ruhe dann wenn ihr euer altes leben
zurück bekommen nichts von dem es
eingetroffen im gegenteil ständig wird
angst uns verabreichten die menschen
werden gespalten ich habe es auf dem weg
hierher gemerkt man redet nicht mehr
miteinander im zug oder im flugzeug man
hat angst voreinander man hat die
gesellschaft gespalten was im plan
gefährliche entwicklung ist und auch die
demokratie ist meiner ansicht nach
tatsächlichen gefahr weil einige wenige
vielleicht irgendwann sagen es reicht ja
aber die lage die lage in den
intensivstationen auf der
intensivstation ist schon dramatisch
also wenn man heute mit der charité mit
dem drk krankenhaus mit vivantes
telefoniert die stationen sind voll die
pflegekräfte sind völlig fertig nach
anderthalb jahren und ich glaube hier
kurz die zahlen sagen wir haben ja
aktuell ich hoffe ich habe sie mal
richtig nachgeschaut 3600 kugel
patienten auf den intensivstationen in
deutschland und wir haben ja 25.000
belegbare betten 22 22.000 belegbare
betten dadurch eine ehrliche frage
stellt dazu ich frag nicht das als
bürgerin jeden tag was passiert denn da
mal bei einer wirklichen krankheits
katastrophe also ich meine wir haben
3600 ich will die zahl nicht kleinreden
aber ich frage mich schon warum wir
nicht mehr intensivbetten haben und
warum uns 3600 betten belegt sind von
kuwait patienten die hälfte davon ja
auch beatmet warum ist das so aus der
bahn wirft das frage ich mich wirklich
müsste man da nicht viel mehr aufbauen
vor allem im nächsten jahren das ist
hauptproblem war ja gar nicht dass wir
zu sein sich in betten und zusätzliche
technik brauchen das haben wir ja in
berlin wir haben haben wir einen profit
19 krankenhaus in der messe gehabt das
nie benutzt wurde und wo vivantes gesagt
hat das können wir auch gar nie benutzen
weil wir gar kein personal haben weil
sie da kann intensiv schwestern haben
die dort arbeiten können und das problem
ist halt eben dass es auch viele andere
erkrankungen gibt die dort im
krankenhaus sind viele schlaganfälle
herzinfarkte geplante operationen die
jetzt abgesagt werden müssen und wenn
wir verlegungen erleben im süden der
republik das krebskranke patienten
verlegt werden von einem krankenhaus in
ein anderes um dort behandelt zu werden
weil in das krankenhaus jetzt co wird 19
erkrankte kommen dann haben wir
natürlich ein problem das ich geimpft
und ungeimpfte in einem gegensatz
bewegung und ich glaube das problem
liegt daran dass die erwartungshaltung
war dass wir 1 65 65 70 prozent geimpfte
haben dass es dann gut sei und wir sehen
heute das ist so nicht das virus hat
sich weiter mutiert die data variante
ist viel ansteckender sogar mit maske
ansteckend und das ist das problem und
das zweite ist der impfstoff hängt gar
nicht so lange sondern schon nach vier
monaten so sagen ja die experten ist der
impfschutz insbesondere für die data
variante weg also die die
erwartungshaltung die in der politik am
anfang da war die hat sich nicht
bewahrheitet und deswegen braucht man
heute höre impfquote und da sage ich das
ist der fehler das versucht man mit
druck und angst hinzubekommen wobei alle
werbe experten sagen es wäre er mit
freude und spaß der richtige weg und
genau dafür habe ich so ein punkt den
sie ansprechen genau das ist das ist ein
wichtiges argument mit freude und mit
spaß jetzt ist die frage kann man in
dieser krise pandemie dieser katastrophe
überhaupt damit freude und spaß angehen
aber der punkt ist ja dem sie machen
glaube ich ganz richtig hier wird jetzt
verantwortung weg delegiert an die
bürger in einem angst modern die zusagen
über wenn du an die ungeimpften bürger
aber auch an die die geimpften und
vielleicht dann ein durchbruch erleben
also wenn er nichts tut böse böse dann
ist das am ende eure schuld und nicht
mehr meine und dafür glaube ich ist ein
minister dafür ist eine regierung ja
auch nicht gewählt zu sagen ich habe
gewisse dinge nicht richtig hinbekommen
und am ende seid ihr aber schuld wenn
das so wäre dann bräuchten wir keine
regierung mehr sondern dann würden wir
viel geld sparen und könnten uns alle
selbst verwalten ich glaub der sinn
einer regierung ist immer in gewisser
weise da ja auch dinge voranzutreiben
und die frage die sich zum beispiel
stellt ist ja diese impfkampagne ist ja
eingeschlafen vor monaten schon immer
wieder auch beklagt worden dass zu wenig
beim tempo voran geht und jetzt ist ja
die große frage wenn das einerseits
beklagt wird warum fehlten auf der
anderen seite dann beispielsweise
biontech impfstoff das ist ja merkwürdig
also der beste impfstoff der welt ist in
dem land aus dem er kommt dann plötzlich
nicht mehr richtig verfügbar was genau
läuft da schief wenn man sich
gleichzeitig monate zuvor über eine
schleppende impfkampagne aufregt dann
müsste man eigentlich doch erwarten auch
als bürger das zumindest genug impfstoff
vorrätig ist napoleon der ehrenbürger
von berlin glaube ich das wasser durchs
brandenburger tor marschiert ist wobei
die berliner damals nicht so viel freude
gehabt haben hatte gesagt auch
unterschätzt
unterschätze nie den faktor inkompetenz
in der politik jetzt haben sie gesagt
der sinn der regierung ok alle fragen
sich jetzt was ist der sinn der
regierung ich breche jetzt mal
philosophische auf ihr was ist
eigentlich der sinn des lebens
des lebens er die sendung
52 nun ehrlich 100 fahrräder sicher drin
ist bild zeitungs mäßig
schlagzeilenträchtiger sehr gespannt der
sinn des lebens besteht nicht darin dass
wir ewig leben werden könnte man uns
eine herz-lungen-maschine und schließen
von der geburt oder in ein
sauerstoffzelt dann werden wir
vielleicht 150 jahre der sinn des lebens
besteht darin auch ein volles leben zu
leben und im moment haben wir eine
politik die im grunde den gott der
gesundheit derart verabsolutiert dass
sie unser leben in wesentlichen teilen
amputiert und um noch einen letzten zero
historisches beispiel zu bringen ich
habe das nachgeschaut in hamburg hatten
wir im neunzehnten jahrhundert eine
cholera-epidemie die wada wirklich
tödlich und damals haben die hamburg
kaufleute gesagt wir können es uns nicht
leisten die gesellschaft auf null runter
zu fahren und die haben dann ihr leben
riskiert auch die kaufleute haben gesagt
vielleicht sterbe ich in der ausübung
einer wirtschaftlichen tätigkeit da muss
auch der sohn übernehmen das geht nicht
aber die subsistenz die selbsterhaltung
der wirtschaftliche kreislauf ist
wichtiger und wenn ich schaue wie die
politik informiert dann läuft es mir
kalt den rücken runter in der schweiz
zum beispiel verschweigen die behörden
sagen dass nie dass das medianalter der
ankuft oder mit cockpit verstorbenen bei
89 jahren liegt und da sage ich einfach
aber das video heute bereits als
zynismus abgetan mit 89 jahren kann man
halt sterben dann stirbt man halt und
wenn immer diese intensiv kapazitäten
genannt werden also um himmels willen
wie sein in einer in einem krieg mit der
pandemie dann müssen wir halt auch die
armee des gesundheitswesens aufrüsten
und nicht die ganze zeit noch
intensivbetten herunterfahren und wie es
in deutschland und in der schweiz
gemacht haben soll jetzt ein bisschen
ärgern wenn wir punkte und wieso hat man
den letzten jahr 9000 serie wer das
intensivbetten abgebaut wie schläge
personal hat man das sieht man auch in
den statistiken von vw warum hat man
nicht pflegepersonal eingestellt
ausgewählt hat seit zwei jahren war
zwar nicht aber man kann das alles
nachlesen dass das nicht wahr ist dass
die betten abgebaut worden sondern durch
die die statistik gibt es einfach in
statistik umbruch als man am anfang hat
man die
statistisch aufgestellten und dann hat
man später die betriebenen betten
gezeigt da gab es immer ein gap das hat
sich insbesondere dadurch dann auch fest
gemacht dass die krankenhäuser für die
betriebenen finanziert wurden und einen
zuschlag bekommen haben insofern machen
wir nicht die sind die sich unabhängig
dieser effekt ist glaube ich nicht kann
man bei die wie nachlesen aber der
flaschenhals ist doch nur das personal